[Music]
all right welcome everybody uh so rachel
is taking a well-deserved break uh from
uh
work
this week and i am
stepping in her place to host the data
science hangout
if you are a repeat attendee welcome
back that this is your first data
science hangout welcome so glad that
you're here
this this session is really meant to be
for you um so i'll ask a few can
questions to start but we want this to
be audience-led so please don't be shy
and ask questions uh you can participate
in the hangout there are multiple of
ways you can have your video and audio
on and jump in you can raise your hand
you can post a question in the zoom chat
and
we'll read it out loud you can put a
star next to the question when you ask
it if you want me to read it out loud
instead of participating then we also
have an anonymous link for you to ask
questions if you want to ask anonymously
with that said just in the interest of
time i figure i'll hand it over to you
matthias maybe let everyone know who you
are and what you're doing and why you're
here yeah absolutely well thank you for
hosting um as an interim uh host i
appreciate it um
a little bit about me uh i my name is
matthias i
had the marketing analytics function at
a company called cm group uh we're a
marketing
technology company um we're at this
point i think the largest family of
products and brands available in the
email and personalization space uh
actually um
closing on another acquisition uh
i think yes the tuesday as of tuesday um
folding cheetah digital into our fold as
well
we
have roughly 70 000 customers
across the globe
and
essentially
utilize or we facilitate uh several
billions of customer connections every
year
um
my team specifically sits on the
marketing analytics side so um
there's groups that report into me
specifically tasked with identifying
opportunities of how we can increase the
revenue streams uh or
reduce cost of acquisition
um
it's
basically split into two groups so
there's an insights and reporting
function
um that deals with a lot of the
questions of like you know what did we
do and why did we do it and how is it
performing and those types of questions
and then
there's a more advanced analytics
practice where
we build anything from lifetime value
lifetime value calculation models
to multi-touch attribution marketing
mixed models and those kinds of things
all with the purpose of supporting our
roughly 100 person marketing team
uh in order to make good decisions um i
guess i'll stop it here because i'm sure
we're going to talk about some of uh
some of this in
in more detail throughout these
questions but
that's the quick the quick uh who am i
and what do i do
very good i mean maybe uh for those who
are not familiar with marketing
analytics give a little more insight
with that or some of the data products
that you can share that you're producing
and the stakeholders
yeah absolutely great question um so i
kind of touched on this a little bit um
so ultimately the the idea of marketing
analytics is can we try to understand uh
how our prospects are acting on a
you know different properties so whether
that's a website whether that's
interacting with um ad properties that
we have um you know that could be
anything from uh you know simple google
page search ads that could be um ott
properties so out of uh
you know
wherever we're buying
ads
we're trying to figure out where do we
get the best marginal return uh on our
ad spend um so
with you know several brands and
products that we obviously oversee um it
always becomes a bit of a
prioritization of like you know where is
the best um you know investment where do
we feel like um we can we can put the
next dollar
in order to get the best return in order
to get more customers for
um you know less cost of acquisition
um
that is sort of like the summary of it
um but with that there's certain or a
lot of different levels of
sophistication so um there's certainly a
reporting aspect into it like you know
how
from a marketing perspective in a lot of
sas companies um the idea is to drive
pipelines so how can we drive
essentially opportunity for our sales
team um to to
drive additional revenue into the
company
um the way that we do this is
through many different avenues from
reporting all the way to you know more
sophisticated um
analytical models
very good and for anyone who joined late
i just want to remind you you can ask a
question anonymously tyler my colleague
has shared
that link um
i
have not had a chance to read the
question but i see zach you posted a
question do you want to ask
yeah so
uh
again so i regime gdpr
uh affects america with uk legislation
how global everything is
so there's more going on to that so
recently of course we saw
we've seen the whole apple versus
facebook apple with their privacy uh
changes making apps have to
explicitly ask for to track your data
and everything
and of course uh
and everyone's anti-facebook and all
their data tracking
how do you see that changing the future
of marketing
because of course
the expectation is that legislation will
be in place globally
the us will likely have one that you
probably haven't another one that's
probably more strict uh with everything
that they do
and do you think that's gonna impact how
people
uh not only go to you to market but how
you
focus on different aspects of marketing
yeah fantastic question and and you are
actually spot on so for those of you
that aren't in marketing or
have data protection
laws to deal with
um gdpr is a law that was written in
2018
in
europe essentially
governing who can access your data who
can
process it
you know where it's processed a lot of
other things um really kind of putting
the um
ownership of data back into uh where
honestly truly should be long right like
the data should belong to each
individual um and giving a bit more um
options to like how you can allow
companies or disallow companies um uh to
utilize your data
there's also um zach us-based
regulations so there's the ccpa so the
california agreement essentially
which isn't as stringent as the gdpr but
it's kind of going into that direction
and i would certainly expect that
there's more regulation coming
i know very recently there was uh
and there was a thing about
um i guess uh uh facebook saying that
you know they would pull out of europe
um i i think that just happens in like
the last few days um and then the
european foreign minister just saying
like okay well then do it um so i think
there's a lot of back and forth that
happens all the time
um
but to actually get to the uh to your
actual question
um
so
i
i
i feel like marketing companies or
companies as a whole um
shouldn't necessarily try to like figure
out you know how to how to skirt those
different things um but there's a lot of
things that can be done to actually test
your marketing initiatives without being
sort of on the creepy marketing side um
there is uh probably probabilistic
marketing attribution for example
um
a lot of the things that we've been
doing internally is relying a lot more
on testing and experimentation so
you know really interestingly more
traditional
initiatives like building marketing
mixed models for example is probably
going to um become a little bit more
involved again um because
you know you aren't going to have that
um
definitive click attribution that you
are used to we already see that
if we look into
channel attribution in different
countries so we operate globally and
i i can tell you that you know for us
users for example we have a lot more
insights into like their paths on our
websites or um you know what their
different channel mixes are compared to
someone like you that would be in the uk
um but yeah ultimately um
from a from a company perspective
um it's about offering
the
the right thing to someone
and i think sometimes especially on
marketing we've gone to
the point where everything and i say
this as a data person everything is so
measured um that people have forgotten
that really truly marketing should be
about
um just offering someone offering a
prospect the best possible customer
experience and that's really what it's
about and the idea hopefully is that
with that comes revenue that's attached
to it and then from a data perspective
it becomes basically my problem to prove
that you know there is a correlation
between
offering a good experience um to
actually having revenue driven into the
company uh rather than saying like hey
okay we're gonna um you know we're gonna
cookie track everything because that's
likely going to go away and in the form
that apparently it exists
great question though i am and i could
talk about this for a long time
those are those are things that are
always on
i think anyone's mind that is um revolve
or working in the marketing space
thank you and yeah probably kid but
probably let someone else want to ask a
load of questions as well
no it's great this is a good one
yeah maybe adding to that what do you
think the future of marketing analytics
looks like
yeah um so
i think we're gonna be going into a i
mean everyone kind of in marketing talks
about the sort of no cookie future right
i certainly think it's
going to move in that direction where
you're going to get less and less
personally identifiable information on
people um
from a marketing analytics perspective i
mentioned this a bit um
i think it's gonna um come down to
um being more in the like uh testing and
experimentation space uh i think um
that that would be the one to still
prove
uh that value exists in marketing
campaigns
and then um you know there there's
different models i think that would
still apply on the probabilistic side
um to understand how marketing
initiatives are performing that i think
aren't going to go away
except with the web 3 uh
doorway i don't know do you want to take
it away
yeah so this might be totally out there
it's something that's uh certainly been
in the back of my mind with regard to uh
if anybody's given thought about it
matthias maybe you maybe you have as
well but um just curious how if you guys
are i mean considering marketing
analytics it's not like web 2 is going
away right but uh but for how web 3
operates are there considerations that
you guys have maybe given for
how you even do analytics in that in
that kind of environment
um truthfully no um i'm not the right
person to talk about that um
obviously there um
there is a lot in that technology and
you know when it comes to blockchain and
all of those things that
are very interesting um
we haven't necessarily gotten there yet
from that analytics perspective um
but i should probably note that down uh
to try at least loosely thinking about
it um
but yeah i wouldn't be the right person
is there anyone on this call that
potentially has uh
some background in in that technology
i
do not but i mean i'm just wondering
whether like all the
information would be with one of those
big tech companies and then we are sort
of given like apis to tap into those
could be some of that is still already
is already happening right like a lot of
the
marketing analytics does happen through
hooking into apis of you know google ads
and google analytics and all of those
different things so um
i i think there's certainly an argument
to be made for that
um
yeah it could be
cool just curious i figured
if if there was a time to ask this would
be great no it's a great yeah it's a
great question we haven't dabbled into
that um technology space for a little
bit um
but uh yeah i'll definitely take that
away because i think that will be an
interesting
uh future-proofing project as well
there's an anonymous question about the
um the size of the data that you are
analyzing or the type and uh well the
real question is are you dealing with
big amounts of data digital touch points
question mark
yeah um so
the quick answer is absolutely
we have a treasure trove of data in fact
um
sometimes it feels a little bit like
there's too much information and it kind
of becomes
um
more of a question of what is actually
interesting rather than
you know can we look at everything
the longer answer is that
we have a bit of a odd
company set up in that we are
essentially a parent company to
different products that are all in them
or different clients that are all in the
marketing technology space so
each of those different brands that we
own so you know cm group the company i
work for
owns the namesake company campaign
monitor but also
sail through celegent emma
cheetah and a few more
there is different levels of
sophistication that we have in terms of
data models for all of these different
products so um specific the longer
answer would be it depends on uh you
know on which brand we're talking about
uh here internally um
but to generalize i think on the
marketing side
we are
probably the most measured function in
our company um we tend to track and over
track everything we can track
um
and um
it's become
the the idea is really how can we find
like those needles in the haystack um to
actually try to tell us what we should
be looking into
um
one of the and i mentioned that my team
is kind of split into two groups there's
like a insights and reporting team and
then there's advanced analytics team um
one function inside of the advanced
analytics team
is like an automation practice where
essentially
we write a lot of code that
deals with anomaly detection
and the idea behind that is
if we have
if i find a really bad metaphor
say like our data is the size of new
york city right
there is no way for us to actually look
into that
um and kind of investigate the whole new
york city so through the automation
anomaly detections that we write um
we try to eliminate sort of like most of
new york city and just tell us okay
these are the specific houses that you
should look into um that have something
unique going on and then the insights
and reporting function that i have would
then actually go into these individual
houses and you know
search for a specific item in a
definitive room um that i hope that
metaphor holds true but essentially um
to to answer that question
i think it's more of a question of how
can we identify what is actually
important out of like that large
treasure trove of information rather
than not having enough information to
work with
i see there's a handout
yeah g1 is that how you pronounce it
yeah that's right um hi matthias i
watched your lead anomaly detection uh
talk and i implemented something on my
own uh slackbot so first of all thank
you for that
yeah i'm just wondering how the insight
finding uh leads to
business decisions so i
i'm kind of trying to balance out the
granularity of the information that i
share and how i'm wondering how that
conversation goes within your team
okay first of all i love that i love
hearing everything about this um and we
could probably talk another couple hours
about um
you know where i feel like business
intelligence has a place in the business
um and where it does not and what we
found and again we have this
specific use case that my team is um
sitting on the marketing team we're
integrating into marketing um and we
have
a lot of people that are the end users
of or the stakeholders of our analyses
that do not have like a quantitative
background right like you might be able
to or you might have to
do an analysis that has a regression in
it
and then explain it to a team of
copywriters
that is a very unique thing that happens
here all the time
and what we found and we have a
i would say decent bi stack so we have a
looker instance sitting on top of a
redshift instance that
flows almost all of our data
from a reporting perspective flows into
that
um but what we found is that building
more and more and more business
intelligence
didn't really increase the knowledge or
data um a data aptitude for our for the
teams because there is a
hesitancy of
utilizing those bi tools
um
you know if you don't if you don't
have like a data background so instead
this is what uh what you're referencing
there um so instead we've actually kind
of flipped it around so we we wrote this
slack bot
um
that basically takes information you
know in this case like you know some
anomaly with detection um and then
surfaces that information right to when
it happens um two people on slack just
pinging them like hey something's going
on in your area um that you should be
looking into so with that process we've
been able to
uh really kind of change of how people
digest analytics in that you know it
doesn't it doesn't um
it's not like an active oh i'm gonna go
and look at data but it's basically
you're being furnished with data in the
moment that it's interesting to you
hopefully based off of my uh
uh my opinion um
to now get to your question um which is
like how do you not overwhelm people
with insights and all of those things it
definitely is like a definitive or a
distinct um
sort of area that you have to walk the
fine line between uh not you know
shooting people and spamming people with
information
but what we found based on like the
iterations that we went through with
this thing
is that as long as you're very precise
with what someone wants and like
understand
what someone's exact requirements are
for specific pieces of information so
for example
our director of performance marketing
she wants to know
every time when our cost per click falls
below a certain threshold based off of
where we would expect it to be um or if
any region
performs out of the ordinary in terms of
impressions or click volume so when that
happens
that's when she gets like a slack
notification that we um uh we wrote you
know hooking into a data warehouse and
shooting it off with uh with r and and
slack
um
so uh
to hopefully answer your question and i
kind of like took a very long detour so
i hope i did if not please
please ask again um
what we found is that the success of
this
um ultimately comes down to how precise
you are in understanding what someone
actually wants to know
and then
giving that person
that information
what we found less success at
was to hook into like generic channels
and just kind of um having more
broad insights pushed into these
channels because
as soon as you do that and you do that
on a
recurring
cadence
if it's not pertinent to someone then
they will stop reading it after a little
while so um that was the i think the one
takeaway that we've had
um after sort of thinking about this a
little bit more and getting some
feedback from people that you know were
exposed to it
that you know it really kind of depends
on
how
interesting is this information to me
and can it actually help my job uh be
easier if i have this information
did that answer any of what you're
saying i know i kind of like went way
out there so definitely feel free to
tell me that i
i didn't help with that question
yeah no absolutely thank you so much
good yeah great
how do you go about
getting those initial requirements or
getting feedback from people that this
is what i want
this is kind of what i want but it's not
really what i want
how do you encourage people to be honest
yeah oh great um
i think it's more it's uh first of all i
think of data products as
living and breathe breathing things i
think um data products are not something
that you
publish and then let go they're kind of
like you're forever tied to it
especially if it's something that pushes
information to people um
so you're gonna have to be open
to
feedback from people
ultimately you know we are
as analytics we are a shared service
that is a
service provider in some shape uh to the
greater marketing organization so
we like our success is measured by how
well people adapt like the data that we
give them
because
if if we didn't then you know we can
have all this information if they don't
actually use it to change their behavior
if they feel like they need to change
the behavior based on a data point that
they see
then like why even give someone the
information so
so i guess that's on the back end like i
everyone should always be open to
you know
making another version of it or like
getting to like the next iteration
on the front and though um how do we
make sure that we understand like what
someone's requirement is
i think
um
the big thing that i found here
is that
it helps to try and kind of try to get
to like the
core of what someone's actually trying
to answer
rather than getting into like a
solutioning process too early so
sometimes we have people that will come
to us and say like hey um i would like
to see i would like to get something
sent to me that tells me how i'm
tracking against the end of the month um
in terms of
pipeline just making this up
and i would like to see it by region and
i would like to see it by marketing
channel and i would like to every day so
it's like in that case someone came to
us already defined sort of like the
report criteria that they would like to
see
um and we've we can certainly build that
but what we've actually found over time
is that doing that without actually
understanding what their true question
is because
they wouldn't come to you if they didn't
have a question that they're trying to
answer right in this case maybe they're
trying to find out um you know
maybe you know in this case
you know end of month pipeline could be
something that they're trying to see how
they're tracking against the target um
you know how how are they going to end
up at the at the end of the month so
understanding more of like why they're
actually interested in this kind of
information um
and then trying to see whether that is
truly the best way
of giving that to them like this
specific already defined report um i
think a lot of it happens there um where
you really speak through
you know let's let's put away what you
have in mind for a second and let's
understand what you're actually trying
to answer like what's your question and
then can we try to come up with a
process that would give you
you know or get you very close
to getting all the information that you
need in order to make a decision on you
know whether you can answer it or not
very good i want to make sure that we
get to the chat questions i'm going to
uh go in chronological order here rick i
see that you had a question i don't know
if you feel comfortable with jumping in
uh yeah sure thanks a lot um uh matias
really i enjoyed your answer especially
to the anomaly detection and delivering
the results with the with the
slackbot i didn't think it was uh off
topic i think was really spot on because
it really struck me that
um it's kind of ironic because you're
working in the marketing department and
actually there was a marketing problem
you're trying to sell something to the
people and you want to see that they're
buying it basically and i mean the
people that you're talking to would tell
you the exact same advice that you're
giving me too much information and it's
not the right information and i'm going
to ignore it and as marketers they would
they would appreciate that immediately
they're advertising in the wrong spot
and driving too much wrong information
to the wrong people in the wrong spot so
it seems like it's all kind of connected
in that and and i feel that oftentimes
we do this as data scientists i wonder
if you agree
as scientists in general i think we tend
to service our needs because i spend a
lot of time making a really fantastic
pipeline or algorithm or look at this
how beautiful this model is and they
don't care they just want to know the
answer right like i don't i don't need
to know why google put this email in the
spam folder i just want to know that the
junk is getting in the spam folder
although they have some wonderful
algorithms in the background that does
that do you think that we oftentimes
service our needs instead of the needs
of our end users
i completely agree with that um i mean i
i think it's sort of a self-made problem
on the data science end too right like i
mean
if you are
if you're trying to digest any kind of
content that's written um you know in
the data science space it's always
content about like the newest new shiny
thing that came out
well not
a misnomer here like not shiny but like
the new sort of um you know the the
newest thing that came out uh i you know
a while back everyone was talking about
like gpt3 like all of those things are
like things that i think we've done a
little bit to ourselves where we want to
do like the cool stuff um
you know uh
data science or like let's say like
machine learning might be a good example
in that even where um you know i think a
lot of companies go out there and they
now understand like hey we should
probably hire data scientists because
that's what people do now
um
without you know ever paying attention
to like well maybe there should be like
a data engineering function first
to actually build the house before we
can hire like an interior decorator that
would be the data scientist you know
coming in and making everything pretty
like actually have to build the walls of
the house first but they may just don't
even have the data but yeah and i think
we do a lot of that yeah i think you're
spot on with that i i certainly
do it i i i try to be mindful of it
one thing that strikes me is that um i
feel that oftentimes
they don't see how much work went into
doing something when you do show them
that result and i feel that we
constantly want to kind of up our game
and show how much we're worth and that
okay we're really adding something to
the bottom line and we're really proving
our worth because i think there's still
some like all right like was it worth
having this team and hiring these guys
so do you feel that
there's ways to
really show the value of your work
without just i think we make it sound
more complicated than it is to do that
are there better ways than just over
complicating our our analyses and our
presentations
i
ryan i saw you unmuted
did you want to add anything yeah
i don't want to take over your talk but
like i think about this all the time
like like i've been part of my life
forever and
and um
i love that this has come up straight up
because this is this is make or break
for data science like it really is we
will only get so high until we solve
this problem right like so it's it's a
great topic
um
i think part of the piece that is part
like that causes this problem or kind of
two elements one
if we talk about the two different
parties the data science party and then
the business party we see different
things as cool
right like we just do like different we
have different values of what is cool
and you talk spot on about like what we
think is cool the shiny objects the how
that's not cool to them if you use sales
as an example what's cool for them is
making their commission
like that's what's cool that's what
speaks volume right so understanding the
language to talk about is part of it
but how do you get there is what we're
talking about and it's probably one of
the most
under discussed in my opinion
boring
more challenging
and not really startupable so you don't
get a lot of the uh financial attention
because data literacy
right it's just straight up literacy and
i'm not talking about like okay how
what's the syntax of writing something
and how to build i mean what can i do
for you
just at that core level
what can data and analytics do for you
other than
increase your shareholder value for vcs
like like really what can it do and we
have this perpetual problems for most
educational systems is data science has
gotten us really well at certain levels
from mathematics
engineering compsci
stuff like that
but no one else is learning this kind of
concept so there's this salt or oil and
water kind of piece and we
in our education systems we're not
really bringing that cross pollination
between the two parties so how do we get
there but like rick i'm having that
right now with
marketing with hr and all those pieces
and it's bringing them along the journey
and like forcing them to write stories
i know it sounds silly but sorry for all
the emails that are picking up from the
background um to write stories and in
that time of gathering requirements and
turning it in fun i educate them
this is what that means that's what it
is so they see like
holy
there is a bunch of stuff happening but
that's why you can't get it to me in a
day that's why it takes you so long to
refine it and like they kind of learn
along the way not that i want them to
have a phd in machine learning or
anything i want to be like yeah that's a
question that they could ask or no that
that we will never get there that's not
we're not advanced as a society no i
took over your time so i'll just
oh no no i i love the i love that um i i
think there's two two things i'd add to
this too um was the first thing um and
this is why i actually like robert's
question so much the first thing truly
it comes down to understanding what the
requirements are on a core level um
more than you know this is the data i'm
looking for but like what are you
actually trying to answer and how does
it impact
you know
like you said for a sales person
ultimately you know how can this data
product that you're building for me
helped me actually
make more money right like that's what's
what it's after
but then rick the second part
is that um i think one thing that we
sometimes do on the data science end is
sort of disappear in the process right
you you do something you have you you
have
your eyes on like oh this i i know now
how to do this i know now what i want to
build
and then you data science does take a
long time and i think it's really really
important like ryan said to take someone
on the journey with you
and kind of like let them know what is
happening throughout
we build things internally it takes
several months of building like a
marketing mix model for example is
something that is probably like a six to
eight months project
if you don't take someone on that
journey with you
they think you disappeared for six
months right so it becomes incredibly
important
to to speak through
and have
a very clear understanding of like look
this is like all the things that have to
happen these are the things that we're
going to need your input for
and kind of like make someone feel that
they have ownership over that project
even though you're the one or your team
is the one writing code
you're
producing that project or data product
for someone else
not yourself and i think that's what
this comes down to
yeah we were we were chatting at our
studio with uh uli uh he was previously
the chief data officer at city of
reykjavik and he was saying that when he
starts a project with a stakeholder he
likes to go back quickly to them
a few days a few weeks and show like
here's what we here's what we can do
here's what we have it's not finished
yet obviously but like this is what
we're thinking about and his perspective
is that makes it real to them it makes
it valuable
to them so what you said made me think
of that
uh i see javier you have your hand
raised
yeah thanks i was just gonna add to some
of the comments and maybe to rick's
question um
one of the things that i feel like i did
wrong in my last job
was make
the end deliverable i mean in my case it
was a shiny app but
is make it way too like
geared for someone that has analytics
training i mean i had like a
faq page that explained a lot of the
different visuals or numbers that you're
seeing
um
i thought it was great because i you
know my perspective was hey
like i have all the instructions here
like someone that is a non-technical you
know salesperson or account executive
they can simply look at this faq and
understand what's happening but
it it
became clear that like the data i was
trying to communicate was not intuitive
and so through a few iterations of like
that app as well as a few new apps
it
like the way i tried to start building
them was to have no instructions
and that really
um
kind of helped communicate all of our
data points or visuals a lot better like
someone who's non-technical should be
able to go into this dashboard
and kind of intuitively understand what
it is that you're trying to analyze or
you know the actionable items it you
shouldn't need to give them training
over training or
a long faq in order for them to like
come out with actionable insights so
anyway just wanted to chime in with that
i i love that you know
i mean what's ultimately our purpose
being in analytics right it's
it's not to produce like dashboards and
give people data but it's to make people
understand what the data means
and i think there's a very definitive
difference between the two um
you know
which is also one of the drives why we
actually went away from just churning
out dashboard after dashboard
because you don't actually know
how someone
receives that information if they're on
their own so
you know i think over the like the last
few
um
months years sort of like the concept of
uh data translation has been like a
little bit more sort of up in front
center i don't know if anyone has like
heard of that but like you know google
is now hiring like data translators
which um you know feels like that's kind
of what we should be doing i guess um
but like that's what it comes down to
and i think um you're on the right path
where
um you know if you're building a data
product
um i think the idea is that you have to
build it in a way that it's intuitive
enough for someone to use it because if
it's not
then um it can become uh it can start
feeling like work and you don't
i don't think that's the purpose of us
right we're um as as people in analytics
or data science
it's our job to
you know give people
more information and help them make
decisions um based off of information
that we can give them um rather than
kind of like adding another thing onto
like their plate that they have to check
every day
so i love that you went through those
iterations and um you know kind of like
thought through like what was working
and what wasn't that's that's great
mike i see you have a hand raised
yeah so
sorry if i'm off being here but
isn't this essentially a kind of agile
approach
you know because
if you
if you listen to what they want right
and then you're interpreting what
they're asking for
in terms of what you can actually
deliver to them
but if you know if
if it takes you six months to get an
answer as you just said in a test
they're not they're essentially you're
not there for them in that time
you know they better not wait six months
to find out that they could have got the
same answer through a normal regression
within six minutes
right so you then got to kind of go well
how do i keep them on the hook and bring
them as you see bring them with you but
keep delivering stuff to them that will
say in the absence of my
all-encompassing model of absolutely
everything
let me give you something just now that
will help you
and convince you that it's worth waiting
six months
is that fair or am i
i like that idea of thinking it that way
um
i think ultimately it comes it comes
down to the ownership idea where
you know
data products are for someone like we're
not building data products for ourselves
in most cases um
you guys there might be instances where
you know like and we have internal stuff
running that just checks you know
whether certain etl processes ran
correctly
but in most instances a data product in
the end
while we're the ones that know how to
operate it how to troubleshoot it if
something goes wrong
how to build the next iteration off of
it
they're not our dashboards or they're
not our you know models they're they're
for someone else and i think that's
where it comes down to where you need to
have people feel that they own this
thing rather than oh this is something
analytics did i don't understand it it
just does something
and i use it um they you know that's
that's where i think you get the
adoption idea from
um and yeah i'm a proponent of the um
the idea that you know you can really
only build a product
for someone
um
if you involve them in the process of
when it's being built um so yeah i agree
with that we kind of use a sort of faux
agile methodology internally um because
the marketing our marketing team isn't
on like um we have a project a product a
project management tool
um
but it's not on the technical side so
like it's not like we use jira anything
where we could do a true sprinting
process
um which again is kind of like
trying to adapt into the marketing
organization and trying to use what
they're using uh even though you know
it's it's not the perfect solution for
us um but i think that's where it comes
down to we try to be as helpful to the
rest of our organization as we can be uh
whatever that might mean
yeah
a wise old statistician once said to me
people are going to make decisions
whether you're ready or not
you know so so you'd best have something
that will at least influence them in the
kind of the right direction and as i say
like being able to at least say it's
worth waiting because you know we can
give you something good now but by golly
by the time you really got to the bottom
of this it'll be worth waiting for
i i love that
yeah i subscribed to that
in the spirit of uh remaining true to
the format zach is the next question i
have time stamped around outlier
detection
yeah so
uh for me like
i find it quite interesting looking at
like outliers becoming patterns
especially as you get more and more data
of course i'm guessing for you matthias
you have already loads of data so it's
not like you're getting lots of data but
patterns do emerge out of outliers
i don't know uh
my general idea at the moment is if it
happens once and it's an outlier if it
happens twice and i
research a bit more and it happens a
third time
then i go actually this isn't an outlier
this is becoming an emerging pattern
of course like scales one-term ferry
depending on how big your data you're
looking at
i was wondering
uh how you do that with the size of data
that you have i'm assuming it's all
automated
it is incredibly interesting to talk
about this question because if you had
asked me um
you know
i think i've been with cm now for like
roughly three and a half four years or
so if you'd asked me before
my time here i would have given you a
completely different answer
because i think from a data perspective
the first thing that you
generally do you know that's the first
thing that they teach you
um
is well just you know the outliers
probably should be normalized out or you
know like if you build a model like you
know like you kind of have to make sure
that it's not affected by outliers
um
i've actually completely like changed my
thinking on that working here
because some of the products that we
have
um
are um
like the outliers are the the things
that matter like the
specifically um for a brand like sale
through for example which is um sort of
on our enterprise end um you know the
marketing there is on the abm side so
what does this mean um
it's it's not a volume business but it's
um you know very much we essentially
already kind of know
uh the opportunities the accounts that
we'd like uh we'd like to target um and
we target that way and um
uh
you know it really makes a big
difference if a singular account like
closes or don't um or doesn't and um
uh
you know from that perspective i've
changed my stance on outliers because it
feels like for
for some brands those are the things
that are actually interesting
and when it comes to outline detection
that is something that
you have to keep in mind that is it for
something where
um it can be like a
something that you're actually looking
for or is it something that you're
trying to figure out how do i build a
good model so you know it still is
statistically valid
um
there is a lot of i forget who said the
whole of this is startupy um but like um
there is a lot of um uh startups now
that deal with this type of issue as
well um like one big one is like outlier
ai i don't know if anyone's heard of
them but they do similar processes where
um you essentially just push all the
data that you have to them and they they
build models for you on the outlet
detection
um
i felt like i want to be the owner of
that so so we do we write all this
internally
because of this reason that i don't want
someone else to make the decision
of
this specific outlier is this just
is it a true outlier that you know a
couple years ago i'd like okay let me
just ignore this or is this something
that we actually should look into
further
because there's a business opportunity
here and in many cases we found that
that is actually what's happening so um
yeah outliers are a finicky thing and i
feel like i kind of go back and forth
between like what i think of them you
know
depending on what type of project i'm
working on whether you know i love them
one day and then uh you know i hate them
on the next because they mess everything
up
okay i'll go santiago is a great
question that he put into the chat all
of them are great i'd say that i
particularly like santiago's are you
still on the line santiago would you be
comfortable sharing i am um so this goes
back to kind of the previous
line of thread of questions
uh so outside of a specific project and
educating folks on that
have you done anything
successfully or failed even to try to
educate the broader marketing team uh
for example
i've considered lunch and learns
or
like a newsletter or something i don't
know any thoughts
um oh goodness um i i think it's
if you figure out how to do it it's the
holy grail um
um
i i in in a sense it is a bit about
setting expectations right like what
does democratizing data actually mean
um
and if you set out for you know like i
said we're
you know a bit over 100 um
people in marketing
um setting out with the expectation that
everyone's going to be like a closet
data analyst that's that's not going to
happen
um
however what you can do is make people
understand the
the power that data has and
the way that you do that is to give them
the understanding or have them
understand how well it can help them
make decisions i think in this process
one of the things that i try to
emphasize is that
i'm not the decision maker on things
nor is my team so when we do analytics
and we provide like a data product to
someone
it is still that someone's decision to
make in the end of what they want to do
i don't take that power away from my
team or from the marketing organization
and i'm very um
protective over the fact that i feel
like data should be a
neutral party to someone um like a
completely
essentially just giving someone here's
everything that we feel like from a data
perspective
you need in order to make a decision
but then the way that you empower
someone and actually have them
understand what the value of information
is
is if you still let them come to their
own conclusion about how this is
decision should be made
um i think some organizations
um have the approach that you know
there's like a you know maybe a business
biz ops team that does all the analysis
and they you know push essentially their
thoughts into like an organization and
then that's the thing that everyone kind
of has to follow
and i think that's a really really quick
way of having people
sort of not participate in this idea of
hey data is actually important because
you can give people data but the only
way if
that people will actually start using it
and that you truly democratize it
has to come from
that person it's not something that you
can
force someone to do um so
that i guess is my longer answer to this
um we've certainly done a lot um in fact
i uh next week i'm teaching the entire
marketing organization looker yet again
so i'm i'm still doing uh still doing uh
sort of lunch luncheon learns absolutely
i don't think we're gonna get around
that um
but uh yeah the idea is people are gonna
to me
people are gonna adopt it
if you
make them understand
that
what they can do with it can actually
make their life easier and they can help
them sort of put move behind their own
job
rather than you know kind of mandating
hey this is the data that you need to
need to use
and this is the right way to do it
i think it takes a little bit more of a
defined approach to make sure that
people actually
buy into your idea of being a data
driven organization
cool yeah that all makes sense
i haven't started this and should i ever
start this i have to pitch this idea and
get by and you know how that goes um
maybe i'll report out some day
thank you
it comes and goes in waves um so um yeah
it's
just keep with it it's it's uh it's
worth it once you get there
morris you've been patient uh thank you
for that but i see you've had a string a
few questions uh
welcome aboard
yeah thanks thanks very much my first
chance to speak met matthias this has
really been helpful conversation for me
i really appreciate this uh my my
context is totally different i come i
work in a non-profit
area and most of the people that are
working in
analytics at least in my part of the
organization got here through some
internal mobility
you know we are the closet and
analysis analytics and people and i
think that's
probably true for a lot of us in this
field um
so
i am looking at
ways to to monitor progress in in
in my just just gaining relevance for
all of this i mean i've tried
uh gone through a lot of iterations of
trying to
convince people that something's really
smart idea or smart models but it
doesn't work
so
how do you
huh
i mean i sense you you feel you seem to
be successful in what you're doing how
do you monitor that how do you know that
you're heading in the right direction
what are the bright spots you look for
yeah um i love that question and also i
i love that uh um idea of having a
non-traditional path into analytics in
fact like my undergrad is in uh
visual and motion design so i'm uh
i definitely have a very
weird path into analytics so i'm on your
on your side in this um
to answer your actual question though i
um
to me like it comes back to like can you
measure how successful this actually is
um and how do you do this is through
testing and experimentation i think the
sort of way to prove that something is
working or not working
the quickest way to do this is you know
if you think about statistics
you know can we understand what would
have happened if we didn't do it or can
we understand what um
uh what's changing based off of uh you
know our proposed changes
um obviously i don't know exactly what
um you know you said you're in the
non-profit space so obviously not
entirely sure like um
you know where exactly that will be
applied but like from a marketing
perspective for example um
we do a lot of uh so when we propose an
action
so say
um we find that you know we are
running a podcast ad and you know or say
the marketing camp
campaign manager for a certain brand
wants to buy a podcast
we would likely suggest from an
analytics perspective then when when
that podcast is bought
can you buy it in
certain dmas so dmas are marketing
regions essentially um
where then we could track okay what's
happening between
all the regions where the podcast was
run versus the one where you know
nothing happened um and then is there an
actual lift in that um obviously that's
a very sort of uh marketing way of
thinking about it but i would suspect
that there is a lot of um things that if
you think about the
if you think about what
would happen if
nothing if we didn't do anything
and you can keep a hold out of that and
then compare to what's actually
happening um that would be a way to
actually get definitive data on whether
or not whatever you're doing is is
working well
um does that answer your question or was
it more from like an organizational
perspective and now as i was talking
through it um are you trying to prove
value for
the organization are you trying to prove
value for
um
you know whoever like what whatever
you're actually doing yeah it's
interesting i think i think it's the
latter um
there is you know there's the mission of
the organization you know the right what
we're trying to accomplish but then also
um you know part of that is internal
uh internal development um
you know my
my most recent mandate is to help us
become more data driven
you know okay you know so nothing
nothing too trivial
but that's so so it's both you know it's
both and um
you know i have great vision of being
able or
trying to help us to
to uh you know like i say accomplish our
mission but i think internally there's
this
there's this idea that um
you know we really i have to shepherd
the resources that we have well and how
do we do that best internally by making
the best decisions so it's decision
making in that it's interesting because
like um you know becoming data driven is
is obviously very best for me like i
think um
if if that's a definitive like goal
which is fantastic
i think one of the questions i would
have if this is like one thing that you
know look uh morris your job this year
is going to be uh do make us more data
driven
um
to go back to like trying to understand
the sort of
what the actual idea is behind what what
they're trying to accomplish um i think
i would have asked you know sort of
okay i'll i'll serve i'll preface this
with the fact that um
i work in a very non-corporate
environment
but if i think about like my corporate
days back in like older jobs
i think one of the things that stuck
with me are sort of like these the idea
of smart goals so
uh essentially you know can you um
measure your goal um and being data
driven is really hard to measure right
so like uh i think if someone gave me
that role that that idea
or that quest you know how can you
um
uh increase data literacy or you know
make people more data driven um
i think i would want to know what does
actually what does it actually mean to
the person that's asking me um
what i've done i can tell you so weirdly
i've been in a similar boat in the past
where you know i just mentioned like
look at trainings so this is sort of
like a
you know hit to the past for me but
somehow i'm still responsible for
teaching everyone everyone that
um but what we've done in the past um
several years ago
one of the things that was on my sort of
you know
list of responsibilities
was democratizing data across the
organization
which is similarly open-ended
um the way that i tracked it and the way
that i could prove it
for these looker trainings for example
i had set out a quick survey before the
loka training um gauging everyone's
understanding of what looker is what uh
um
uh what their level comfort is can they
build a dashboard and manipulate a
dashboard um you know kind of like
understand where the baseline is and
then did the training and then two weeks
later essentially asked them again for a
survey
um which did show like pretty
considerable increases in like how
people felt about how they could use
business intelligence um so that might
be in a way for you if you if you have
to
sort of get buy-in from leadership um
those were the things i would think
about like how can we how can we prove
that whatever we're doing um you know
has
um some success with it and um yeah
that's that's how i did it from the from
the bi side
um
and yeah i i there there's gotta be
opportunities like that
yeah thank you that's helpful
yeah
do you have time for just one last
question let's see i want to make sure
that everyone uh who put a question in
the chat gets it answered i don't think
peter is
on any longer because he said thanks all
but uh so sorry if i'm reading your
question wrong peter but feel free to
jump jump in um his question was how do
you balance steering clear of flashy new
things without keeping your skills
current i don't know if i can um
right so it definitely is a balance i
think that's what it comes down to
because
i think
technology is moving so fast
that if you don't look for those shiny
things and at least know about them and
kind of have an understanding of what
they do
um
then it can be uh it
it can be rough right like uh because
who knows what's going to be around five
years
i think one of the good examples and i'm
going to really completely butcher this
um
uh but if you think about like book
printing right that was like and this is
where i butcher it maybe 1400 1500 or
something um
and then you know like the actual first
digital printer was like in 1990
and then all of a sudden you know a 3d
printer was in like 2000 and whatever so
that i think that is the pace of
technology where you know you go from a
very sort of sort of steady um you know
innovation to like very becoming very
exponential very very quickly and i
think the same is true for data science
the same is true for analytics there's
so many things that are happening all
the time see i feel like i was doing
well on the 1400 to 59 right i gotta pat
myself in the back there
um
but technology is just moving super
quickly and if you don't
um
if if you don't have an aptitude to kind
of like follow things and kind of be
open to learning new things um
and i'm not sure if this is uh if
analytics is going to be a great fit for
you because there's just so many things
you're going to have to keep up with um
on the other hand um
and um
i forget who said it but ultimately uh
um what we talked about earlier
um
you have to keep in mind that what
you're making
is
um only as good as you know people
understanding and people utilizing it
so
sometimes a more simple model that's
more easily read and more um more
adoptable
outperforms the shiny thing
so i think
i think in that in that sense it's
really important to think about the
business requirements so you cannot
sort of let
yourself make that
mistake of okay i just really want to do
natural language processing because i
feel like would be really cool
if it has no application to what you're
doing um so you you can't let you let
your
sort of personality uh try to dictate
what the business needs
i hope that answers it
very good i'll speak for peter and say
great answer um there we go
to wrap things up i thought maybe
one uh how can people find you and then
two
uh any sort of imparting
wisdom um
to people who are interested in getting
into data science leadership moving up
in their career i mean it's really
fascinating since we started doing this
it's like almost like a hundred people
join uh
every week and sort of all over the uh
career grid so i thought i'd ask i'd ask
that because there's a wide range of
audience here
i um
yeah i'm a huge fan of these talks um i
it's it's one of the recurring meetings
that i don't dread
like you know you have these days with
everyone working from home it seems like
there's just meetings and meetings and
meetings
and in many cases
dedicating like a whole hour every week
is something you know
that can be challenging but every time
that i've logged into one of these um
i've just found incredible value so
thank you i guess i'll give that right
back to you thank you for putting this
on
um
they've just been like really
eye-opening um
how can you find me i'm on linkedin um
uh
that's probably the easiest way um
otherwise uh
yeah
lincoln's probably bad um i i don't like
uh i don't i'm not very unselective so
if you send me an invitation uh i'm sure
i'm sure i'm gonna invite uh or i'm sure
you'll accept it um
uh other than that
um yeah i guess email
email me or
find me through a pigeon but i'm yeah
i'm happy to connect with anyone that
has
additional questions about this or just
wants to chat data signs
um the last question that you had was
about like how to actually get into data
science and data science leadership um
i don't know if i feel like a bit
pretentious talking about this and
answering this because i know you know i
i i certainly feel i still feel like i
have a lot to learn um to move into that
realm also
um
but um
uh
in a sense um i think it to me it's
understanding how you can provide
business value to someone um and really
kind of trying to be
um or trying to use your skill sets
in order to make someone else's life
easier and once you show that value um
there's natural buy-in that generally
people uh will help you along the way
um
i um
yeah i guess that's what i would say i
but yeah i don't know if i'm like
there's been some incredible people on
this um
uh you know
that probably have a better pedigree of
answering this uh in terms of building
like a huge data science team on their
um
in their within their companies
i think your answer is
perfect
great
um well robert thank you so much
that was fun
absolutely i mean thank you all i had to
do is tee up a few questions
thanks everyone for participating as
always
next week
same time same place
forever and ever until we run out of a
data scientist
you